how's it goin brows welcome to a new
let's play I know what you're thinking
the [ __ ] is he wearing I was making a
video where Edgar was licking my face
with peanut butter and now I'm all
swollen and I'm a little self-conscious
about it thank you very much
but anyway play some more Bayonetta you
bros love part one I absolutely adore
this game I literally can't wait to play
more let's do this look at all that
sexism whoa whoa okay we're back in the
game oh my god what the [ __ ] are you
there's no way March that's gonna stay
with me by the end of this bye bye [ __ ]
oh oh [ __ ] are you gonna finish it I'm
going it oh you think you can hang on
[ __ ] off
oh yeah brofist of that guy oh my god I
beat the [ __ ] out of him sick and climax
oh my god what is happening playing
sword man throws his sword of course and
the bridge is God the bridge is gone I
repeat the bridge is gone Bayonetta
don't give a [ __ ] now we just stopped
time did you get everything
forgot the caviar she forgot the caviar
everyone
it's not Christmas without having it's
not Christmas without kuvira's let's
finish the climax quickly alright I'm
getting sick of this guy there we go
beat the [ __ ] on that [ __ ] punished oh
I'm naked tunas come on take that
brofist oh [ __ ] yeah
climax oh yes
four come on give me more oh okay
why not
that's pretty hot it's an elephant oh my
lord Oh God Jesus stop why does it sound
like an elephant oh my god what is
happening let's discuss that it's
disgusting
oh my god she saved it Shh well that's
an awkward angle did they have to pick
that angle Jesus come on Japan
they grabbed her ass
yes this is some [ __ ] soft for corn
porn [ __ ] man and I'm okay with it
oh she is pissed now whoa we're playing
okay why not this is for grabbing my
girlfriend's ass [ __ ] oh [ __ ] look how
many health bars he has oh my god jeez
that's cry submitting the [ __ ] out of
him both [ __ ] epic oh my god oh my
god this is clearly King Kong with that
[ __ ] Jesus
are you serious I can't believe Ming's
climax I'm so ready for this climax
that is so [ __ ] FA
yes spinning my hair okay why not my
hair became a demon
parademon why not thanks Japan
appreciate you that was so [ __ ]
awesome
oh god no nuts eraser hey we got our
first goal it's old you I get better
okay what's gonna happen here oh my god
that seems like the bad guy you live in
the sand where the [ __ ] is that I know
the one who destroyed your world
know what nice toast dude who destroyed
love nice lip thing dude
this is smile is their galaxy and his
cloak okay what is happening
whoo the gates of hell I like this all
right
we're black we're black I mean we're
back with Santa sorry did witches get
dragged here is reminds me a bastion I
like it scoffs John's gonna wander
inferno suffering for eternity beams the
brakes
wait so we can't save her I didn't ask
you to tell me what I already know Rodon
especially if you're going to be flip
about that's right don't be flip Roden
you know I got tribal tattoos I'm Mike
[ __ ] Tyson guesstimate that sort of
summon go out of control bayonetta
something's up the balance of powers
that keep things in check don't feel
right does now I didn't you know she's
pretty hot for a dead chick necrophilia
good job Japan you've done it now well
the living but looking at her now
Nash still not a fan Jesus what the [ __ ]
she's not dead Enzo
she's writings your new really dead
after your souls been completely
absorbed into another realm of the
Trinity how many more piercings are you
gonna get just a matter of time cuz I
don't see no way of saving a soul lost
in Hale what about the gates the real
gates of hell I can't stop you from
trying to use it what does that mean I
don't think you got a chance down there
I'll see what I can do about pool of ice
for a while of course she has to be
naked I mean of course you might wonder
she's the heart of an unbridgeable can
alive in this world for eternities
should keep her body in this realm
stable but you'll need to reunite this
with a soul if you don't try and bring
her back
okay got it you give the medallion to
her oh that way will save her life
got it no problem ironically the virus
called gates to hell
and so you've got a jet right oh my god
what no forget about it I do not know
uh-huh
I appreciate the situation would you
know what today is
my kids got cookies baked for me at home
the waiting for me and I still got a
place here tonight I got a please save
that Oh real Santa take care of the
presents
yeah let the bugle hey yeah I believe
but Eddie Nana you can't pull one over
on those two little [ __ ] let me tell
you let go let go of me I like are they
sometimes like [ __ ] beautiful ain't
this a [ __ ] oh I love this game
it's so [ __ ] beautiful
I hope you're enjoying it too it's
[ __ ] it's such a trick I I have a
feeling it's gonna get crazier and
crazier the further we get along I can't
wait to see what next is gonna happen
all right
hey good mountain of cymbal Venter fee
bill by joint supposed to be between
Inferno and Paradiso they say there is
an entrance to Inferno the gay
of how somewhere on this mountain where
we go inches we're going to Sweden hell
no one even knows if it's true enough
cow only reason this overgrown rock is
worshipped like some God in the first
place is that no one's ever been able to
get close to the dead
it's like you don't want your ceiling
but the [ __ ] New Zealanders but it's
wrong with you Oh worse and don't even
try and fly a plane in that place on
bottom Oh better ready for your soul
doesn't have a long walk to whichever
afterlife Yahweh we keep going right
I'll wait for you and know it at the
foot of the mountain just hurry up with
whatever it is you got to go and get
back there all right another Australian
racquel with a minibar - got to keep
myself busy while I'm waiting forget
about it
ah I love those miniature drinks me too
oh no [ __ ] I mean her knees look weird
oh god what is this going I mean yes
okay we're in the sky
of course I would she be in the plane I
can't believe you I didn't know the
in-flight service was exclusive to fat
Italians Brenda posted fan you know that
reminds me you owe Alex the kid for the
Charter oh what oh my god this is so
ridiculous
Bayonetta I love you
okay we're going to the gates of Hell
this is so awesome
sorry I need to stop jerking came up
that's Fitbit thimble vendor what the
[ __ ] kind of name is that bad place when
you look at it oh but you gotta have a
death wish to get close to that damn
place if you ask me talking about my
back here's me the heebie jeebies what
where did these cards come from
something mysterious oh there you go
giant ass dragon again
so do regular people not see those is
that how it works this is where I get
home say hi to the wife and kids
oh my god yes what kind of spell is that
oh don't ladder the squirrel oh my god
no oh my god oh I was not ready for that
J sir I'm on my way
whoa give yourself for a bit longer Oh
oh my god is this the best game best hey
guys what's up here we go oh my god I
became a [ __ ] Panter like you gotta
appreciate the game just for her [ __ ]
detail and beautiful it is
okay we're swimming now what the [ __ ] is
this
okay alright this squirrel again whoa oh
here we go enemies is so [ __ ] amazing
gameplay I [ __ ] love it it's so
beautiful to play like I have no idea
what I'm going but I feel like I am the
best player in the [ __ ] world
I am definitely looking at the scenery
right now
100% so much scenery to look at up were
out
hi guys what's going on did it did it
did it did it did today - oh never mind
go in this seems safe seems safe enough
let's go Bruce what do you think good
idea bad idea [ __ ] oh my god is that
[ __ ] dragon again I'm a better plan I
can't believe it's on the Wii U I can't
believe it's on the Wii U look at this
it's amazing here we go what's up with
that church man
and of course as more enemies I don't
know why I didn't expect anything else
but I'm okay with all got it they're
murdering all the people why should
smiley
oh okay he's fighting do we know this
person it's a squirrel these punches
don't know went quick what'd I ever do
to them
well this guy is a total of korah this
guy's radical this guy's off the chain
man
well this is like what your panting is
cool what is this pants tiered like what
do you keep water bottles there do you
says did you [ __ ] yourself
[ __ ] I shall clean Luna [ __ ] I knew it
wait well Lisa won't be a boring trip at
least you shave your armpits nice golf
clap
ha you can see me putting on quite a
show little magician oh you like that
huh
wait want to see the climber oh god
don't use the word climax you're clearly
enraged silly girl
oh she sailors laugh you'll have to do
better than that
to earn a tee time oh my god Jesus
Christ I'm just an innocent little girl
lost in Wonderland suffering at the
hands of the Queen's subduction get one
huh
enough riddles how can you see me
because we're both in purgatory
purgatory Oh her tour you between there
are we heading to thimble vendor on a
shopping trip for mummy little one
oh my god yes baby boom mummy the top of
strangers I stay on my way I'll make
sure you never get in it again oh it's
got a card scaring off with their heads
in
why is there shadow walking to the wall
damn
they must have heard me
what is going on something happened more
enemies
why do they look so [ __ ] weird to
both heaven and hell are against us it
seems like torture attack Oh
oh my god yes you can pick up weapons
where oh there it is okay how do I use
it why okay wow look at that [ __ ] oh my
god that's [ __ ] awesome it's a strip
it's a stripper pole
it's a strip oh my god this is my life
Negros oh my god oh my god that's so
cool
remember God what is it getting now I
feel like a kid again playing this game
hi step [ __ ] again I can't wait to
kill him or is your head oh there it is
haha if you're looking to the kid he
went that way
ha ha
no way he should kill it that easy
oh [ __ ] you pissed them off there
holy [ __ ] afraid I don't have time to
dance too long friend is waiting for me
a friend is waiting for me
okay let's get the [ __ ] of this game
wait wear it what the [ __ ] is the man
you're taking his dick what the [ __ ] is
this oh my god he's so disgusting
here it is come on baby suck it Oh God
Jesus what oh oh oh my god
why the hell not
Gold baby that was smooth like butter Oh
cat is so much detail in this game I'm
so impressed I feel like I'm playing a
chart again in the weirdest [ __ ] way
ever hey guys how's it goin it's it's a
minute so they're after you too then
okay tell you in OT keeping secrets even
seekers Oh God
she calls herself nothing I love sorry
but since this is your bloody mess
do you mind whoring the [ __ ] up and
getting rid of this thing now that's no
way to talk to a lady no wonder your
guardian angels are trying to give you a
good spank
oh my god spanking you've already been
following me so let's make a deal you
saved me
I'll show you around this joint heading
to fimble venta aren't we that makes two
of us and it'll take two of us hold it
love you seem to have skipped school the
day they taught basic negotiation skills
you're supposed to negotiate from a
position of strength not just me a
one-trick pony
oh my god this is the best what is
happening what what just happened um
about that trick see you need my power
too ha ha ha oh my god now what's - I
suppose I don't have time to give a [ __ ]
about who you are why you're going to
the mountain take me there and make it
quick
you stay with me and I promise you'll
end up in one piece
got it ok alright alright stop before I
show you the way love some kind of love
with little condition uh-huh I need to
go over my lesson again first learn to
talk to a lady
Sultan welcome
I don't react to being cold little one
the name's Loki and what should I call
you luck I'm your man there you go
Oh mayonnaise are also raisin
take your pick sir a sir
you don't look like a certain well
Bayonetta it is let's move little one
hey I just told you my name is you learn
your name when you become a man oh yeah
you're a [ __ ] squirrel [ __ ] that's
right I'm from the [ __ ] hood I pop
one and you're all y'all asses I'm bear
your [ __ ] net all right
I'm a better flag just kidding on my
Panther what
oh god it's an ambush Oh have to smack
that ass Wow
I need a stripper pole back right
[ __ ] now oh it comes the big guy okay
all right
are you're bein more like you're lame ha
ha ha ha
thank you very much I'm here all night
oh my god so we get [ __ ] awesome oh
my god you see this do you see this [ __ ]
so [ __ ] cool man
oh my god and we did it we got his
weapon right whoa what the [ __ ]
whoa are these ice balls so it's like
cyber Venice try to keep up oh [ __ ] now
they [ __ ] again
Jesus
I'm so sick of that [ __ ] mecha dragon
diamond angel thing I'm sad a sentence
cuz you asked tall done that makes total
sense
we're gonna fight this guy now
I'm so [ __ ] excited so technically
this guy's oh my god face is his nipple
oh I like this new weapons oh we gotta
be careful and done oh my god what
happened what happened what happened of
course we're here now how's it going
everyone
oh my god I'm beating the [ __ ] out of
him I [ __ ] love this look at the
background and everything it's so
[ __ ] amazing I'm gonna climax give me
a [ __ ] climax come on Oh Jess oh we
[ __ ] healed that [ __ ] oh stop the
[ __ ] I love it
yes bye-bye [ __ ]
Oh
oh please no more mommy references go of
me so little one
what's all this sovereign business about
not a clue though boy haha well whatever
if your sovereign this is going to get
in my way our deal is over at if we're
going to have to meet any more of your
friends you better learn to take care of
yourself I'm quite alright on my own got
it
your tricks aren't going to work forever
two one
what just happened oh my god thanks
little magician maybe you've got more to
offer than I expected
did he just say I'm getting her booty I
can respect that thank you don't get
frisky oh my god what there what that is
the one is it not
it is an umbrella I will never forget
that face oh [ __ ] we picked we did
something bad to the wrong person
all right breasts ha I can I've joined
that episode there I hope you enjoyed
watching please leave a like if you
enjoyed I really appreciate support let
me know if you won one more
I love playing this game it's such a
pleasure in the most Awkward way
possible thank you so much for watching
I'll see you bros tomorrow with new
episode and as always stay awesome rest
oh my god oh my god coming down I told
you red